hey everybody is Jessie and coming to
you a little bit later than normal today
so I had a meeting scheduled for 2:00
p.m. which is my normal time and then
that meeting ended up getting cancelled
right before so ended up not really
needing to postpone it but at that point
I had already had it on on Twitter for
hours and on YouTube that I was going to
do this at 3 p.m. Eastern instead so I
decided to stay with that so I'm gonna
catch you up from what we did yesterday
and then we'll decide what to do today
I'm gonna leave it up to you all what we
work on there's a few different it's
probably at least 3 different paths that
I'm thinking we could we could go down
today and actually let me know if the
stream is all right I'm getting a
message that the stream was not so good
in terms of quality so it did say it's
good now oh no no it's not so good so
just let me know it it looks like I'm
uploading it I'm like over 5,000
kilobits per second right now which
should be fine but let me know not sure
if there's much I can do to fix it since
we already started okay and now it's
getting a little faster it should be
good alright awesome it looks like in
the live chat all right we have 1080p
okay
so basically since yesterday we had some
pool requests so I had some pool
requests from Kevin and from Gavin so
there's now a github pages page for this
so I'm not I'm not 100% sure about this
but I'm pretty sure that the form will
not work on github pages but the rest of
the site should work so it'll be a good
way to check things out even when I
don't have an grop running so if you go
to I'll just I need to put a link to it
now in the readme file I think that
would probably be the best way to go but
I think it's like it's normally what is
it github and I can't even remember how
the URLs are formatted I haven't had
anything on github pages for a couple of
months so I'll find it we go into
settings and just show you okay here we
go all right so here's what it looks
like when you first go there so it's fus
- mark on github I oh okay that's what I
thought and then slash Resource Center
so resource - Center when you go there
it says page not found obviously because
that's we haven't set that up in react
router as a route so if you just click
on the side nav there you can go to the
different pages so they work like I said
I'm pretty sure the forum won't work but
that's that's not really a big deal
you'll be able to see the rest of the
site and
let's see I'm gonna paste that in the
live chat and I guess I'll probably end
up putting a link if there's not already
a link to it because potentially I might
I'm gonna have to check usually repos
will have it like right up at the top
they can get a link to it so I'll try to
do that you know you know what I'm
talking about like right up here it's
ready to link to it right up here so
it's really obvious so I'll do that
later on it's not really important for
right now see okay so basically so that
was thanks to Gavin's full requester
Thank You Gavin
that was that was all him in terms of
getting that working for github pages
which was for this project a little bit
more involved than you would normally
need normally do to get your project on
so check out that pool request if you
want to see the details he included some
links to some more in depth instructions
for doing github pages page with create
react app also at a pull request I think
we had - from from Kevin one was
refactoring so the the major one was
refactoring what we did yesterday so if
if you take a look at this I mean it's
gonna be hard to see it as I'm scrolling
around but if you check out the repo
everything should be up to date on the
master branch now so that's if you want
to check that out that that would be the
best to look at but if you check out the
server yes things are looking a little
bit better more organized and Sebastian
also explained his his reasoning for
refactoring in the way that he did on
that pull request so that's like maybe
requests 30 for something like that 35
somewhere around there also we had an
update to our example file for the
environment
Abel's to take into account the new
variables that we were using all right
so now now you're all caught up actually
no there's still one more thing so I now
have the actual content of the form
going in the emails and going to the
right projects so before we just had in
the emails just some some string some
demo string that came with the example
from the SendGrid
api for node so we got rid of that so
we're actually sending basically just
I'll show you I did it because it's
right here on the screen
so all I did was here where we're
already making an object with all the
all the fields so the key value pairs
with the field names and then the value
that we put in
so I decided since we're already looping
over all that here why not make a string
that basically has the same the same
thing so I'm just grabbing the name of
that input and then whatever the value
is and then for now I've just included a
break and I needed to change the type
let me find out where this is
at some point there was a type that I
needed to send in with the through the
SendGrid API and I can't find where it
is it should have been below
is that thought it was
okay so text slash HTML is the the type
so what before we had text slash plain
all right so since we're including HTML
now we had to change it to be HTML all
right otherwise it will just it'll
actually show the the BR tags so that's
all we had to do to get it working for
the email and then we just take that
same field string and we use it we pass
it here as well when we make the folder
so now I'm this is an additional so we
weren't passing this before and we also
now where we're actually passing the the
email address that gets entered into the
form and that's gonna be the title
instead before we just had tests that we
were passing in so now if we go up to
our make a right make folder function so
you can see we have the name and then
the content so for our title we have
name enough for description we have
content okay so that's all the further
I've gotten right now probably want to
clean it up a little bit so I want to
send two emails right now I'm only
sending one email so I have to see what
the best way to send those emails are I
don't know if there's some built-in way
I'll have to read through the
documentation to see like is there some
built-in way that I can just you know
put in pass in something else to say
like alright we want to send the same
email but I'm not sure we might do like
an entire entirely new email new
template sent a different one I may want
the user to see something different than
the project manager sees not sure I mean
probably could just simplify it and make
the email for the user it's enough that
the project manager
see that something came in and then that
way they'll get an extra notification so
that things don't don't slip through and
[Music]
yeah and that's so basically for the
server part of this we're nearly
finished you know it's just a little bit
of kind of cleaning up the way the email
looks yeah which is not really it's it's
a bit tedious because you have to change
things and then send an email and then
check to see how it looks probably not a
bad idea to check in in different email
clients but it's gonna be a really basic
email this is it doesn't need to you
know it's an internal email and just
kind of a courtesy thing to say hey we
got we got your data we got your
submission and it also gives the user a
chance to review what we got because
they may have accidentally you know type
something in wrong or forgot to put
something in and they get one last
chance to review even after they've
submitted and correct anything so we
could do that we could work on this we
could even try to look up some security
things to do for our uploads or we could
move on and start working on some of
like the UI of things like just some CSS
with the layout which we have sass set
up now thanks to Patrick we haven't
really done anything with sass yet so
maybe we could work on that the other
thing that we could work on that would
be a little bit more involved we haven't
done yet is doing the resource section
for logos so I'm going to show it to you
also I know I've showed this before
about most likely have some people
watching that did not see it previously
so I'm gonna pull this onto the screen
logos okay so here's how the logos look
now so you can see it's you know they
just automatically rearrange themselves
and then we also have you know some
filtering going on so this is actually
not it's not going to be too difficult
because if you remember from our last
project
you all remember Fabian from from Paris
who did a bunch of pull requests for the
last project I haven't seen him for a
while in the in the live chat so maybe
he's busy with work or something but he
had some pull requests for our resource
section the original version of it
before we had to change it and we had a
masonry layout similar to what we had
for the logos but it worked with Reax
so this is all you know jQuery it's
using isotope so we can't just copy this
over and have it work so we could
probably look back at that pull request
of Fabian's see what he did and then
apply it here so we won't have to start
from scratch but I think that'll
probably be the best way to do things
and instead of you know the isotope
filtering we probably could just do our
own filtering with dot filter and that
should work that should work well it
should accomplish the same thing the
only thing that'll be different is
there's you know that you see there's
like a slight animation we won't have
that animation I'm sure it's possible
with react but I've not really worked
with you know animations in react like
on on a state change so we'll see if you
know when we get there so anyway those
are the three ups and I'm gonna repeat
and really quick because I there was a
lot of explanation between
so the first option is try to you know
really polish that server j/s file with
possibly some security and proper email
templates second option is do some UI
work using some sass and just clean
things up a bit make it look nice third
option is try to do a masonry layout and
react for all these images for all these
logos I'm gonna give everybody just a
minute I guess to to vote in the live
chat and while that's going on I'm
actually gonna check out the live chat
here because I haven't checked it at all
yet and I'll say hi to everyone also I
have had a few people join in on
Instagram already but if you're not
aware if you'd like to see what my
office looks like and what I look like
while I'm coding you can check me out on
Instagram the links in the description
if you're joining on Instagram and you
don't know what's going on I am coding
and if you want to see the code check
out free code camps YouTube channel for
a livestream of my screens alright cool
so Victor says hi great to be part of
this project I'm beginning to like
coding more with each step thanks free
code camp awesome you're welcome thanks
for watching
hey everybody I see a lot of people were
saying hello I'm not gonna go through
one by one I was gonna say say hi Google
user r-va s is is this just Java it's
JavaScript so a little bit different
different programming language than Java
but yeah it's basically I don't want to
say it like this because there's a huge
thing on Twitter a couple weeks ago
about this but it's just JavaScript in
regard to react I don't know if any of
you saw that but they were like some
people were freaking out about
everyone always says react is just
JavaScript than they were saying like
everything's just JavaScript like what
do you I don't know I don't know what
the big deal is I mean I think it's at
least I've always understood that it's
more nuanced than like obviously it's
not exactly JavaScript right but anyway
don't want to go off on that tangent
let's see ish each to me says can
someone tell me what this project is all
about I'm not sure if someone answered
doesn't look like and so a brief
description we're using reacts
specifically we bootstrap the project
with create react app which is just a
way to get started building react really
quickly without having to worry about
configuring webpack or anything like
that so we built it with that we're
using material design for for our UI so
specifically we're using a framework
called material UI and we're blending
that with another material design
framework called materialized but the
project itself the whole purpose of it
is just to provide some resources like
logos to people where I work at the
university that I work at and then also
allow them to request services from my
department I work in marketing through
an online forum and so that online forum
sends emails after you submitted and it
also sends data into a project
management system through the through
the API it's right gives the project
management system so that's basically
what it does and so we're just working
our way through that that project
Linn Poole says hey it's a shame I
started watching these streams only now
now I'm watching only day two and trying
to catch up with these well yeah it's
good that you're watching now at least
so you didn't get in sooner but some
people have said that they're able to
watch the streams on for time speed and
it still makes sense so maybe you can
try that I haven't tried it yet myself
but who is I think bill watches it
yeah Bill's in here hey Bill I think
bill has said he's been able to watch it
at four times speed so it might help you
to catch up a little bit more quickly
okay Gavin good I'm glad you you sent a
message about the so right before I
started the stream like literally two
minutes until I was going to start the
stream I noticed that Gavin had sent me
a message on Instagram I read it quickly
and then realized I'm not even have time
to respond to this right now so anyway
the messages that he sent was about
starting a slack channel so that we can
keep the discussion going even outside
of the live stream so that's a good idea
they've actually been some attempts to
do this before so we we hadn't then I
think we still have an IRC channel which
I haven't checked into in a while and
I'm sorry about that if you've been in
the IRC channel but I just I just
completely forgot about it so we have
the IRC channel although I admittedly
IRC is a little bit harder to figure out
if you haven't used it before then
something like slack somebody did try to
make a slack channel but then nobody we
couldn't get in and we needed like
usernames and passwords for it and so
that didn't work out so I'm definitely
open to a slack channel I think that
would be nice I
if anyone would like to set that up I'm
cool with that and just let us know how
we can join I think that'd be cool if we
do is select channel though I mean let's
try to keep it
same as it is in here definitely very
friendly for new people any questions
are welcome about code try to get along
and not not get angry and argue with
each other so just basically I like to
have a really kind of nice laid-back
environment where anybody can feel free
to ask questions without getting
ridiculed for being a noob or anything
like that if you want to have battles
about which editor is the best I'm fine
with that but no battles about like
really really serious things because I
don't want people to get there are other
places where that kind of discussion is
appropriate but not not on the free code
camp YouTube channel or slacks channel
okay cool
so anyway Gavin that's a thank you for
that it's a really good thought so
definitely think that would be cool if
someone could get it going alright so
Krish says hello lol what's going on
who's this learn get first yo yeah I
agree
gets it's awesome so this is Jesse and
I'm building your react app live on
YouTube and yeah so I'm not gonna teach
you teach get but we will learn some get
along the way cuz I'll explain what I'm
doing with it okay so I assume
everyone's had a chance to
let me know what you'd like to see all
right so I see we have a vote for doing
things with sass logos animations Oh
Gavin reminded me about the Pomodoro
Club
I just always forget Thanks all right
I'm starting to foam adore o'clock now
which means I'm about to start coding
like masonry component how do I see the
industry Dylan asked how to see the
insta stream my Instagram name is in the
description for this video so check you
can get the name there and then go into
Instagram and I guess you can search
actually I've never really tried to see
obviously to see my own stream so I
guess you'd be able to search for me I
do like a people search and then it'll
it'll show that I'm I'm streaming live
ok it looks like
it looks like I had a few people that
are talking about the the masonry layout
and maybe one vote for doing things with
with sass so I think we're going to do
the masonry layout today and we may end
up actually doing some things with sass
to make that layout look nice so we'll
probably get a little bit of both so if
you if you voted for sass you're not
going to be disappointed completely so
that's good I figured you may have been
getting tired of working in server j/s
anyway because we've been doing that for
at least like three days maybe four days
okay
one more all right one more comment and
then we'll start Damion says I'm heading
back to day 9 may I make a suggestion
when a new module is used can you show
how it's done on day 4 I was struggling
and was able to add babble to dev
dependencies then googling works ok yeah
oh um I'll have to do a better job of
updating on that so I'll try to remember
to let you all know when things are
added into package.json you know just to
make sure that you know when that
happens you got to run NPM or yarn and
install the packages otherwise stuff
probably won't work right okay cool
Gavin has created a channel so
Gavan if you replace the periods in the
link with an asterisk then you should be
able to paste it in there and then if
anybody copies it they can just replace
the asterisks with periods so some some
people have been able to get links in
there like that all right so let's go
let's first things first let's look up
the code that we're going to use so it
should be should be in this repo let's
see if we have we may have a branch for
it
I so don't have a brand I was hoping
there'd be a branching to be easy I'll
have to look back through let's go to
that page if you're not familiar with
git this is one of the great things
about get and version control in general
so the final version of this project
which is now finished and launched does
not have the code that I want to use but
a previous version of it that we moved
on from does have that code so if I
hadn't been using git or some type of
version control that code would be lost
to me unless maybe like I manually copy
the file and saved it somewhere but now
I can go back so I can go to the file
which should be resources and I can look
at all the previous versions of that
file so I can go down here and I can see
everything that's changed and even who
changed it so let's scroll
okay so that's why I did the new UI so
anything before that should be what we
want so I can go in here and I can see
exactly what changed on that particular
commit on that that version of the code
or I can just view it view the whole
file and that's what I want to do so it
looks like we are using react masonry
component which I think Gavin had put in
the in the live chat so that's what we
will be using let's see if we had
anything else yeah this we this is
really all we need to import so we will
be pulling in that package okay we're
gonna be using some of this so in-state
will have basically the an active tab
right so we're not it's not really gonna
look like a tab layout so if you see
like what we have here I wouldn't
necessarily call this tabs it doesn't it
at least it just doesn't feel like a
normal tab layout in terms of like the
way it animates and everything but
that's essentially what's what it's
gonna be
so we're gonna keep let me make this a
bit bigger so we're gonna keep this
I'm I haven't decided yet exactly how
I'm gonna pull on all these images and
what what I'm gonna use to manage those
images so not sure if we're gonna have
to make any calls to get that
now this code is gonna have some extra
things that we definitely won't need
we're not gonna do this in it tab stuff
so this this was to make some things
work that we're using jQuery and we're
definitely not going to use that the
actual let's go to the actual markup all
right so we have this masonry component
right so we're wrapping everything in
the masonry component and then each one
of the images will basically be here
where we have our div that's that's a
column and then a card inside of that
will have the same thing so we'll have
our div that's a column and then inside
of that we're not gonna have a card
we're gonna have an image and then that
in this case that connects in
down here
and we actually are putting in we won't
need to do so much of like the
categories and things in our drop-down
we're not gonna do that we're just gonna
have essentially I was I was thinking
for a second I would show you how this
looks if you don't remember this project
but we can't because we we changed it so
I can't really show you how it worked
out but anyway that might be a little
bit hard just to see with the code I
mean if if you had seen some of the
shows when he did this maybe it's a
little easier so let's just get to it
just put something on the screen just to
get it start to see what this is
actually going to look like so the first
thing we're gonna do is get this package
so if you're not familiar with how NPM
works then this will be a nice
introduction
so in our package JSON file you'll see
we have this section for dependencies
now this this file has gotten somewhat
large so don't worry if this looks like
a lot of stuff if you're just starting
out on your project it'll be a lot
smaller more simple and that's as it
should be for project starting out so
this project we've been working on this
for this is day 15 and there's at least
a dozen people working on it right now
between you know me and and all of you
that have submitted pull requests so
it's starting to get a bit complicated
but basically what we're gonna do is
we're gonna pull in that that package
react masonry component alright and
that's going to help us get our masonry
layout and have basically do a lot of
things that we don't really need to do
by hand from scratch right because that
would be kind of tedious we may as well
use that package when we do
that package is going to show up here in
our package.json under our dependencies
this is going to get synced up to github
so that anybody who wants to copy that
you know they're gonna clone that
repository they can then run NPM and
it'll check this and it'll load all the
things all these things that you'll need
for the project to run so I know a lot
of you probably know that you know but
for people who are just beginners
starting out that's kind of how how it
works
at least for people that are using like
NPM based based things I know other
programming languages have similar
things I can't remember I can't remember
what they're called and other languages
right now but so you know if you're
familiar with like package managers in
other languages then it's similar thing
that's going on here but it is nice that
we can all have the same things and the
same versions of these packages all
running so we should in most cases all
be able to run it and it should work all
right so let me pull over my command
line so my other screen right now
I will make this bigger I know it's
really small right now so this is my my
terminal or command line to tell you the
truth I don't really know if there's a
difference between saying command line
or terminal if they're interchangeable
maybe there's a difference I don't
really know if if one of you knows let
me know so it's possible that I don't
sound very smart though maybe I'm using
them wrong but if you're not familiar
with it I mean this is where we can type
in commands mine looks a little
different than the default because I'm
using something called I term - this is
for a Mac if you're on Windows you can
there are different things that you can
use as well I can't remember for sure
commander or something I can't remember
what I have on my PC but you'll probably
want to download something other than
your basic terminal just to add you know
some extra features that will help speed
up your development so any in this looks
like my commit didn't work I didn't
realize it okay let's check this out
first
thank you so we have well how did I fail
this many tests
all right so let's check this out this
would be a great learning opportunity
what to do when things go wrong so I
right now we're set up to run some tests
every time we commit code so we're
actually doing it several different
things so it's checking all the code for
errors its formatting all the code and
of standard format and then it's running
some tests to make sure everything's
working
so we failed some of these tests
and it looks like we're failing for
navigation error
hmm I'm I'm gonna try it again just to
see what happens I don't know about you
but sometimes I'll just try to do the
exact same thing again and occasionally
I'll get a different get a different
result all right so we are getting the
same result not exactly sure what's
happening for the sake of just kind of
moving on let's let's skip the test I
really hate to do this because I think
it would be good in case you are having
these problems but this is kind of like
a big detour from what we were trying to
do so for now at least I'm gonna add
no actually that's for husky I don't
think this is gonna work we'll try I'll
try it anyway oh yeah it did work
awesome okay
all right so I had thought that I had
pushed this up to master and I told you
all that at the beginning of the stream
so obviously that hadn't happened I just
didn't look back at my my terminal so
now we're gonna pull down the correct
package so I happen to be using yarn
which instead of normal NPM which you
can you can use that I'm using yarn we
can do your an ad and then react pastry
component and I'm gonna double-check
let's see okay double check the spelling
so I don't know if y'all heard but there
were some some people were taking like
common packages and then publishing
their own packages that had the same
name but just misspelled slightly and
then those packages were stealing
environment variables that's just
supposed to be private so which is
actually crazy because I don't know if
anybody was watching the stream so one
of the early streams I started to type a
package name and it occurred to me that
someone could do a lot of damage if they
misspelled it and I don't know if
anybody remembers that but there's video
evidence of this and which may not be
good for me because someone might say it
was my fault but I doubt that anybody
watched my my stream and get the idea
for that but it actually did happen so
at the time when I said it was just
hypothetical like that would be bad if
somebody did that but people were
actually doing that evidently and so
basically just double check when you put
this in that you're actually spelling
everything correctly otherwise I don't
think it was really widespread that
didn't seem to be that many people
affected and I think NPM is there taking
steps to prevent that from happening but
just in case it may want to you know
double check that
okay so we have react masonry component
and you can see now it shows up here
right so it says here's the name of the
package and then here is the version so
by default if you don't specify a
version it should give you the latest
stable release which you could certainly
specify any version number that that you
wanted that's available on NPM let's see
okay at this point we can go into our
our component for the logo view so logos
Jas
so you see we already have some things
in here and I'm actually using this I
was using this to test out the generic
card that Rohit had made uncommitted
which is going to be really useful as we
start to build out some of the other
pages but for now I'm gonna remove this
because we're actually gonna put the
logos in here now so we we don't want
this in here right now
and we want yeah we'll probably want to
leave the row and yeah let's pull in
our will pull in masonry so we're gonna
import masonry from react masonry
component and then that'll allow us to
use masonry in our component and then
I'm just gonna bring in right now I'm
copying I'm gonna be copying a lot of
things over from that file that I showed
you from a previous project so we're not
gonna need all of this we don't need
price we may end up using data later on
but we're not right now actually so in
comparing the two projects I think type
type will be the equivalent to our
categories that ran along the top so
we're gonna keep that we all we don't
need these categories so once we get
going we may decide we can change this
up but I think this should be alright at
least to start with
and
okay so I don't think we need to do
anything like with lifecycle methods
right now so I am going to copy over
that masonry a constant that we had so
we are going to keep filter all right we
can get rid of this filter because we
don't have price we can get rid of the
category filter we can I'm gonna get rid
of the card the resource card
yeah we get rid of the card and instead
we are we're gonna end up having an
image I don't think if there's a wrapper
so for now I'm just gonna put in an
image we're gonna use a placeholder
image I'll have to check in material UI
to see if there's some component like
wrapper for responsive images or
something like that
we'll see how it how it looks for right
now I think it'll be alright just to use
the image element and let's see what are
we even using for images that was for
stock images
actually I probably could I could use a
real image I think we have I must have
moved to my other screen let's we could
maybe use a real logo
and we'll probably need to add some
extra logos as well we've gotten some
new logos since since I first made this
so let's see what the here we go
yeah that that should be I was just
double-checking to see what where that
was at in the folder structure I think
that should be publicly accessible
I would normally up obviously just just
do I get the image you know URL but
since its wrapped in all these divs I
can't actually get to the image the real
image itself so that's why I'm getting
the URL like this so let me put this in
and I'll need to do I need to put the
beginning of that in
okay my Pomodoro timer is up so I'm
going to do a 5-minute break from coding
to check out the live chat and then
we'll go back and do another Pomodoro
session so I'm gonna scroll up a bit and
see what I've missed
okay I see Kevin said maybe it's time to
split the server into various files I
agree I figured we'd have to at some
point because I mean I knew it was gonna
start to get big with all the and we're
still not even doing everything that we
need to do so it's gonna get even bigger
so we probably should split it up
yonis ask can you show me a lesson use a
CSS class to style an element please
probably end up using classes to style
an element possibly in this district an
you stick around and watch we'll get to
that once we start getting some things
on the screen I'm sure we'll have to
adjust probably I'm thinking at the very
least that top row of categories that
we're gonna put on there we'll
definitely need some adjustment okay
unless I could find a material UI
component that does exactly what I want
we'll probably need to adjust it and we
will most likely have a class that will
we'll use
Jeong woo says hello everyone which
would go to editor in terminal well I
think I've already said my terminal I
uses item two on Mac on Windows
I think it's commander but it's spelled
like Cmdr something like that and I
guess that's how you pronounce it
I've always just assumed that's how you
pronounce it but now that I think about
it I'm not even sure
and then my editor is Adam but I like
Visual Studio code as well
UNICEF's when did you start coding like
if the very first time I ever started
coding was when I was in high school so
probably I was 16 or 17 years old and
that's if you really want to consider
like HTML and CSS coding which I'm not
going to get into that I've some people
do or don't think is coding so after
that though like really like starting to
code and get paid for coding it's only
been I don't know like four years ago
yeah three or four years see so I've
been a full-time basic full-time
front-end developer for almost two years
now at this university before that I was
freelance for about two to three years
and for most of that time I was doing
coding work when I first started out it
was not not so much coding just maybe
like some CSS stuff here and there
Oh Kaabah says please is the entire
project going to be made available for
download after it's been completed yeah
the project is is it's already available
on github so you know you can certainly
clone it download it whenever you want
and it'll still it'll be left up there
whenever it's completed - and then of
course the videos will all still be
available for as long as free code camp
wants to keep them up which I assume
they want to keep them up unless I don't
know maybe if I
I really mess up bill take him down but
I think they're happy with what I've
been doing so far and it looks like so
Gavin has made a slack channel and he
shared the link but let's see I'm gonna
clean up the link and paste it in since
no one else but me is allowed to put
actual links in so my timer is run out
I'm gonna get back to coding in a second
but I do want to join the salaat team
for free code can live awesome so this
link I just tried the link it should
work and I've put that in the live chat
I'll probably end up putting this link
in the video description as well so that
everybody can see and we won't have to
keep putting it into the live chat
all right so making a mental note of
where I'm leaving off at in the in the
live chat and then I'll come come back
to it soon Wow looks like cool I do have
a couple of viewers on the on the live
stream on Instagram which is cool if you
are viewing I'm sure we probably didn't
hear the announcement at the beginning
of the stream if you want to see the
code check out the free code camp
channel on YouTube and you'll be able to
see what's on my screen I know you could
you can see the code a little bit in the
corner of the fee but not enough to
really know what's going on all right so
let's restart our Pomodoro timer we do
another 25 minutes of coding so where we
left off basically is we've imported the
masonry we've imported masonry from the
react masonry component NPM package and
right now we have set up our state just
our defaults and then we have a constant
that's going to be masonry component and
we're gonna put that we're gonna insert
that down here right now we don't really
have a lot we'll probably just have to
fill out
we'll just put in some data here just to
give it something to loop over but at
some point we'll have to decide how
we're gonna import the data which will
basically just be the image URLs part
probably the name too so we can give it
a nice title attribute maybe alt
attribute as well
okay so sorry for the weirdness going on
here my um I have some package for my
editor that's Auto formatting things as
I go along and occasionally it gets
weird right now it's getting weird
because I never closed out this element
there we go now it's yeah there we go
that's better okay yeah so let's try to
see if we can get something on the
screen so I'm gonna bring over from the
code that is on my other screen now that
I showed you earlier from our previous
project I'll bring over some of the
stuff
I need to find it
it's quite a large component
sorry I'm scrolling through this file
and I cannot find where it there it is
finally
actually I'm gonna yeah let me
alright I'll pull this in this is going
to be a bit more than I wanted to start
out with in terms of complexity but why
not we'll pull it in and get get
everything work in here so I have I'm
gonna pull in every so we have a row
we're gonna have a row for our tabs
and we're gonna put that above so we're
gonna have to make a container right so
if you've never worked with react before
you can't have two components to sibling
components side by side within this
return it has to be wrapped in one so
that's why we're wrapping it for right
now I'm just I'm not going to name it or
anything this is gonna be where our tabs
go and then let's make another row and
that's where get we're gonna insert all
our masonry stuff all right cool and the
Instagram livestream has ended that will
be available for the next 24 hours if
anyone wants to watch the recording of
it so thanks thanks for joining if you
if you joined in okay so let me that
just briefly let you know what's going
on here I think there's one more thing
that I'll have to bring over to make
this work but what we're doing is
pulling basically adding in all the tabs
that we're going to need so we are going
to have to put something in state for
this to go to go through and put each
one of these and this is using the
materialized version of tabs so we
probably are gonna have to redo this a
bit because I would rather use the
material UI version if I can if it works
for this for this use case but for now
this is just going to make the tabs this
then is going to make rows actually yeah
I can't do that
so I'm glad I saw this so basically this
is going to generate rows so we don't
want to put this in its own row it's
going to generate rows for each tab so
every tab will have its own
corresponding row so that when you click
on a tab that row will will show up
it'll become visible each one of these
components these masonry each one of
these rows will be populated with the
the images the masonry components that
belong to that particular category okay
so hopefully that that made a little bit
of sense to you but we do need so you
can see here like we we have nothing in
terms of rows to be of type yeah we need
we need to add some things in for this
to work
see
okay so we need our
[Music]
actually I put this in the wrong place
so we had originally we had these things
inside our render so let me get rid of
this there we go okay that looks better
it makes more sense did I leave off yeah
I left this off
okay so now wow this this formatting
will be fixed when we go to commit so
it's it's a little bit terrible right
now so here's where we're gonna where we
have our tabs so right now these are the
tab names for our other project so we
will change those but you can see we're
getting the active tab name from this
state okay so right now it's all and
that's that's what we want to keep it so
that's that doesn't need to change and
then where we have the tabs so just key
value pairs for all of our tabs so we'll
leave it like this for now we'll put in
the proper names in a little bit all
right so our masonry component is
filtering based on the active tab value
and
okay then once it's filtered then it
goes over everything we're getting that
right now from data so what we need to
do then let's provide some data
[Music]
yeah let's provide some data just to to
get this working so all we're gonna need
right now at least with some objects
with with the type ACF type let's remove
this ACF because that was unique to the
wordpress api with it the particular way
we had it set up some student posted
okay so we'll just have a tight
should think how the data came through
in WordPress that we had it set up it
would have just been an array of object
okay so
audio
in capito
okay
okay so this should at least give us one
at least one in each category so
something for it to loop over we may not
even need this I'm not gonna take it out
right now
but I don't think we need it okay so
this I'm just gonna double-check that
this image is actually gonna work on my
other screen yes it will okay great
okay so we have tabs great thank you
okay so one thing that's not gonna work
for now is obviously we're not
initiating this we haven't pulled in any
of the styles or JavaScript to make this
work so let's see how it looks I don't
really expect it to look great but
something should come on to the screen
and we are gonna have a default by
default it should show everything okay
yeah let's save it you'll see what
happens
and where did I put it
I guess
[Music]
I can't find where I moved everything to
sorry about that be a minute oh well
I'll just go to localhost and let's use
that 9000 all right now let's check out
logos and see not a hundred percent sure
it's gonna look good here actually out
what did we do
actually not seeing anything at all
that's not good
probably just syntax error yeah it's a
sin to expected token to syntax error
but it does it's not actually telling me
very much
mmm
yeah yeah for some reason
that's really odd for some reason my
server isn't just not responding
and it doesn't really say this evening
happen so let's let's still try to start
the server again
mmm
what an idea
all right so Patrick says I should run
yarn run Lintz
I know now at least we'll get
and get some messages about what could
be the problem car title is used flat
bondages
oh I'm not using these so that's
something and what else did we have the
react JSX space before closing rule was
depreciated alright I'm not really sure
what this is all about but at least I
can verify that I fixed the other
problems which I know I did but ok so
I'm getting this thing
I'm gonna paste this in on my other
string and just do the search
all right so the first two links are not
giving me great information or solution
to that let's see at least we have some
nice formatting now so as you can see we
the Auto formatting worked like it was
supposed to alright well let's at least
give this a shot
okay let's see all right I'm gonna go to
the live chat and see what you all think
I don't Shive for 3,000 as well yeah
nothing for 3,000 is not giving me
anything either
daya Ron says I thought I saw a masonry
spelled with two S's in your file yeah
it is hopeless two S's so that was yeah
that was from the original pool request
and I just never changed it
yeah so it doesn't it doesn't really
bother me I know what it's I know what's
going on if it bothers anybody that
that's misspelled I will accept your
pool request if you really want to
change it otherwise it works some fun
with it
well it did work it's not working right
now
hmm
this is
[Music]
okay cool so I got it started here so
not sure what the issue was
this must have an alt prog okay so we're
getting a warning here about having alt
prop which we were gonna put in an all
prop anyway on that image element so not
a big deal I'm not exactly sure what so
in case you haven't been watching last a
few days we actually had like two
different servers running and to test
out our form in the uploads
we're running things on localhost 9000
but then originally with create react
app we had things running on three
thousand so we basically the three
thousand seems to be working the nine
thousand wasn't good double check yeah
for some reason it's not but we can try
to figure that out later for now
hey look at this we got logos okay cool
so the images aren't working I wonder
what they given us is it a field the
load resource
it's really odd not exactly sure why
that resource failed to load but so you
can see we have so our tabs are
populating and then we had four elements
but four objects in our array for our
data and we see four here now I don't
expect these actually did it work cool
okay so this actually does work
basically because we were doing this
kind of thing right with with state in
our component but you can see the Styles
don't work which was expected but we
should have liked audio should have to
text and video should have one element
okay great so all that's working so
let's see if we can make it look a
little bit nicer first thing I want to
do is check out material UI and see what
they have in terms of tabs if they have
something that's awesome then I'm
willing to switch otherwise it might not
be that big of a deal to just take what
we have now add a few styles to it and I
think it could work
the only thing I'm worried about is we
have quite a few options so I'd like I'm
considering changing how this this works
because that's a lot of options to just
have right across the top of the screen
so let me try to find where I had the
example of the live site now just to
show you in case
in case you don't know whoops it looks
like it logged me out so you log back in
hey good news about this so I'm you know
a lot of you have expressed your
opinions as to how terrible this
currently looks I I hope that soon we'll
be hiring a new web developer in the IT
department and they handle this site so
basically the first task of this person
will be to start redesigning this
according to basically the styles that
that I tell them to try to match up with
what else for doing so hopefully that
will be looking better sometime within
the next few months so haven't hired
anybody yet but I did we had a phone
interview with another candidate earlier
today so hopefully we get it goes okay
yeah so like twelve plus we'll probably
want to add in all sorry I like twelve
or thirteen across the top which is we
used a really small font to basically to
make it work I don't like doing that
because it's hard to read okay I
couldn't remember how I got did this
before so we do actually use a drop-down
at some point
all right that's not bad actually let me
know what you think my Pomodoro timer
just went off so I'm gonna go to the
live chat in a second but let me know
what you think do you like that it's
it's spread out across the top like that
in a row and then it goes you know to
this or do you think it should stay as a
drop down all the time you know is this
just too much and is the font too small
so I'm not sure um it's nice to be able
to see all the categories I guess all at
once
so anyway I'm undecided let me know what
your thing let me turn on turn on the
timer for five minutes
and
yeah we'll probably do I probably won't
do a complete Pomodoro cycle I think
what wind up doing is just do a little
bit of styling to make it look a bit
better and I kind of just really want to
use a little bit of the use some sass
because it's been a long time since I
used it so but otherwise it's starting
to get about time for me to leave works
so probably maybe do ten more minutes of
coding after this I would say maybe give
or take a few minutes alright so David
asks how do you get night mode on github
what's the package why do I always
forget this
it is called github dark so just search
for github dark and then check out the
options for installing it I am using it
with tampermonkey so I'm running the
scripts as soon as the site loads with
tampermonkey to set all this up
Gavan says why have no daman as a
dependency I'm thinking it should be
more of a dev dependency if it needs to
be in there yeah actually I think you
might think you might be right Gavin
yeah no I think about it am I missing
something is there some is there some
reason why no daman should be a
dependency and not a dev dependency
maybe I'm missing something here but it
I'm thinking it could be a dev
dependency
all right so David's asking about
electrons so if you notice electron is
is here under dependencies and let's see
electron is for I'm sorry I'm looking
through because I think this question
just got answered are we using electron
for tests I'm gonna see when did we add
that I have to go back through because
we've had quite a few pull requests so
I'll have to check and see where we we
actually added that in
so it looks like electron didn't get at
it until actually that was Gavin's pull
request anyway so I'm not sure if Gavin
is still watching our fries back but it
looks like that last pull request that
that you added was electron so maybe you
would be better equipped to to answer
that
okay it looks like so it looks like the
way we're doing it currently live with
the categories across the top and then
when we get to a smaller screen it
shifts to a drop down it looks like
that's what we're gonna go with that's
what seems like everybody has agreed on
that
oh okay alright thanks Gavin for
answering so basically so Gavin added in
electron in the pull request because
there are errors on the tests saying
that electron needed to be installed so
um sex that's interesting
we are gonna have to sort out there have
been some some errors happening with
some different people so we're gonna
have to sort out what's going on with
that
I haven't well with the exception of
today I've never really had any errors
with the test so I haven't really been
able to replicate anything but you might
have to sort that out okay so my five
minutes are up
let's do I'm not gonna do the fool
actually I'm gonna set this for ten
minutes and just we'll do a bit of
styling let's check out
it's your UI I always say
I can't spell
there we go all right this is what I
wanted let's see see what the tabs look
like
all right not really sure I'm not really
sure if these tabs are really or what we
want
just usually you don't we have a lot of
items I've don't think I've ever seen
that many items in tabs for material
design so I don't I just don't think
that's gonna look great so maybe we
should try to just style these a bit on
our own and see see how it looks so
let's take
let's make a SAS file for this
styles as well
okay so we've made through the command
line we made this file so we did the
touch command and then specified the
directory and then the file name so now
we can see our file here logos ok so
within this now we can edit this let me
see what our class names we're using so
for right now the tabs or what I want to
focus on
[Music]
okay so we have you uh and just a lies
in there
okay
let's check dev tools this is probably
common but I've I find it helpful to
when I'm not exactly sure what I want to
do to use dev tools to change some of
the Styles just so I can immediately see
what's happening and then once I figure
out about what I want to do then I go
back to the actual file and start making
some changes but for now I mean we're
already getting some of the behavior we
want so it's it's already displaying in
a row which is good
we do want to
with style
[Music]
actually was
type that's what you want none okay so
we've done list-style-type:none that got
rid of our little our little dots their
little disks so we definitely want to do
that you all tabs so we can go back here
and let's just say tabs so I did have
somebody earlier say how do we style an
element with a class not sure if you're
still around but this is how you do it
so we have the class name of tabs on
this UL so now we're gonna say tabs and
[Music]
list-style-type:none alright and now we
have just styled that and you can see we
actually it's automatically created the
CSS file so that SAS is compiling now so
if we go here we can see now it's C I
said we haven't really done anything
that SAS specific so it's pretty much
exactly the same just have this up
online but if we had done something that
was kind of a SAS only thing it would
have compiled a valid CSS immediately
okay so we have our tabs unstyled let's
see
I do want these to be let's check out
our allies so right now we have some
column some column classes being applied
to the allies so let's remove those and
see what we're left with I don't want to
have to fight the column classes I'd
rather start with less and then build up
okay that's so that's what was happening
oops I didn't import the CSS file so we
need to do that let me go to another
page just second copy it
you know I don't want it from index that
when it from
here we go
okay so we do need to import that file
that CSS file okay and doing it like
this what it it helps keep everything
kind of you have really small easy to
read files if you name them in a decent
way then you should be able to
immediately know what they're for so in
this case our files are named for the
most part after what they're what
they're doing we like either what
element or component or even view that
they go with so it's pretty
straightforward
it looks a little bit nicer than having
one giant CSS file it's easier to find
things in okay so you see now it's
applied that we don't have those little
little disks and we've also gotten rid
of those Styles for the collar
so we have our list and it's now in a
row we don't want it in a row see
display:block this is such a common
thing that I have to do and I can never
remember there we go
I just can't ever remember how to get it
to work let's do something sad specific
so within tabs we're gonna put a tab and
put float:left okay so obviously you
can't do this in regular CSS so it
compiles to this which is proper CSS
I shouldn't say compiles that's not
really the right term right
okay so now you can see we have the
styles here let's give a bit of padding
so let's give it a pixel all around and
don't give any pixels all around and I
do I do want a margin as well so the
reason being so the padding will
actually be like clickable area but the
space that's margin will not well we
should probably put it on here yeah
let's get rid of that let's put our
padding here that's really what we
wanted I want to maintain that that
clickability
here you see that the target will be
larger so if somebody doesn't exactly
get out in there it'll still work okay
and then on the LI we'll add a margin
and I don't want any top or bottom
margin so I'm gonna give it zero there
and then let's go another eight pixels
on the sides so you see it it looks now
and you zoom in it's easy to see
all right so you can see we have on each
one eight pixels of padding all around
and then eight pixels of margin on the
left and the right so that should give
enough of a target so that remember this
is only gonna be desktop now so we don't
have to worry about a tap target
otherwise we would want a bit bigger
like more like 40 48 pixels but since
this is going to be for a mouse we can
get away with smaller but that should be
enough it should be very easy to click
and then also because we have that
padding in between so that there'll be a
16 pixel gap in between each one where
so that people won't accidentally click
at least it'll be a little bit more
difficult to accidentally click one that
you didn't mean to click all right the
last thing
alright let's just let's just put this
in so under the tab we want a margin:0 8
and then within the tab we're gonna have
the a tag and we want that to have
padding of 8 pixels I'm gonna save that
I also want to see what will happen if I
put I want to see what happens if I try
to Center I don't know if I brought I'm
not sure I brought this class over from
materialize we'll see in a second Center
I didn't so let's go with
so here's another way to style react
components you can actually just put a
style tag and then drop down into
JavaScript by putting the brackets in
there and then make an object and then
that object will then be your CSS so in
this case I want to do text align and
that needs to be camel cased and Center
and let's see okay and that hasn't done
anything no it hasn't so what I need to
do what I want to accomplish is to have
this stuff centered so I need to do
something with this
trying to think I did this somewhat
recently I had the same issue I'm trying
to remember what I ended up doing
alright my times probably about it let
me double check before I oh yeah it is a
I must not have heard the the beeping so
anyway just to let you know what the
next step that I wanted to do is have
this be centered so probably going to do
some type of some type of centering like
- Otto maybe but then I'll need to give
it a list so I need to do like with so I
could do something like that I don't
really want to do that
[Music]
yeah it's not now I remember the issue
that I had before was that if he tried
to do the float then you can't get
stinks so like right now it's obviously
centered but I was doing the float to
get it to all line up so what I can't
remember how I how I fixed that anyway
he's display flex in the line Center
okay so Dayron says use display flex and
then align center or center content
items okay cool off to try that
display:inline oh yeah there we go
Sebastian awesome that's what it is
okay so that's that's what I was looking
for that's how I pretty sure that's how
I solved it previously
okay so display:inline probably the Flex
thing would have worked as well but if
we add display:inline and I don't think
we need to do we need to keep that we
don't need that we need this yep okay so
we need text-align:center on this div or
can we put it on the UO okay we can get
away with putting it on the UL so let's
do that
and that's nicer to put it lower down
anyway and then we don't have to add
another element and then on the tabs
itself will go display:inline save that
and let's get rid of this this Center we
don't need that and then also this which
I mean that was good for demonstration
to put that in if you need to but since
we have that separate CSS file I'd
rather
everything in there so here we go what
did I miss excellence the float we gotta
get rid of the float there we go okay so
we have everything centered lined up I
like the amount of spacing and padding
the text size I kind of really would
like to go bigger on the text size so
we'll see about that possibly also
different on what we'll have to see some
more styling about how we want to do
that but no bad definitely looks better
than it was so that's a good start
yeah a good start
[Music]
probably not gonna commit this right now
because I was getting all those errors
before so Wow why not let's let's see if
we can commit and not get the errors we
didn't really do anything to fix them so
probably will get them again but we'll
see so let's do a git status and when we
do get status it'll show us everything
that we've changed and everything we've
we've added so test upload txt
see
I'm not sure how the test upload got in
there
all right so definitely don't want to
commit that
okay so we definitely did change these
so that's why it's a good idea I always
do it and usually it's not really
necessary but I do like to do against
status before I commit especially if
I've been working for a while in case
I've forgotten that I changed something
or if I inadvertently changed something
I didn't realize it so now all these
files look good I am I have actually
worked on each one of these actually
server supposed actually I'm not really
sure what I did in service request
so let's check it out
uh-huh that's all usually it'll show me
on the side a different color for the
lines that have changed and it looks
like nothing's changed so you can do a
git diff to see what's changed so this
is logos which it's fine we know a lot
of stuff changed in logos server sequest
it looks like just formatting so
probably probably when we ran that that
command just to do some formatting it
probably just reformatted something in
there so yeah so nothing actually
changed it just got rearranged a bit
okay that's cool I'm fine with that
all right so I'm gonna do a git add and
then I'm gonna put a period there and
that's gonna add everything so if we do
our status again everything's green I
mean it's ready to go ready to be
committed so we'll do a git commit em so
we can put a message in line and we'll
just say
me
that's that's pretty much sums up what
we've done so currently I have no
standards on commit messages for this
project I'm thinking about making some
sort of standard or they're adopting
some standard for commit messages from
from somewhere else so might end up
having some better messages here at some
point but for now I just haven't decided
on it currently in my course all right
see we passed all the tests not really
sure what was going on with that before
maybe it had something to do with the
server so if you remember I had to
restart the server so if I had to guess
I'd say maybe it was something with that
but we can see we passed all the tests
let's push this up
so now all that code is available in the
repo on github I'm gonna go over to the
live chat and answer any questions you
have in there so if you do have any
questions please put them in the live
chat now I also take questions on any
other social media platforms or even
email if you have some questions for me
later on if you aren't interested in the
question answer session you're just
interested in the code the code portion
is over so thank you so much for
watching you can you can safely leave
now most likely won't be doing any more
coding otherwise let's get to some
questions
all right so it looks like I've covered
a decent amount of the chat already I've
done a done a good job of sticking to
the schedule of the Pomodoro sessions
today
okay it looks like there was some
discussion about using the grid CSS grid
layout so I'm probably not going to do
that for this project since you know
I've already have the masonry stuff set
up so I know that works I like how that
works so I'm open to using the grid
elsewhere if Ness Patrick says that it's
it's only at about 70% browser adoption
right now so maybe not at least for this
unfortunately there are a lot of
computers on campus where people are
using some really outdated browsers so I
don't attempt to support the really
outdated browsers and in fact I think
there's value in not supporting them to
try to force up you need to force them
to update especially for security issues
of using browsers that old but I think I
still would like to have have things
look decent even on slightly older
browsers but John Hanson does say if you
use CSS fallbacks within the grid layout
you can still use it in production so
okay cool I mentioned earlier that I was
saying compile when I was talking about
sass and I mentioned I'm I'm pretty sure
that's not the correct term so Sebastian
says maybe trans file Alberto says
transfer yeah I think trans file is
probably I mean I I use transpile when
I'm talking about what babel does with
JavaScript
I mean sass is a CSS preprocessor yeah I
don't know it doesn't really matter you
all know what I'm talking about
it takes the sass and it turns it into
CSS whatever you want to call that
process that's what it does
now Kevin Kevin had to leave the stream
and watch it two times to catch up so
awesome glad you cut up
oh okay so that file that I wasn't sure
about was from a test and then Kevin
says it gets deleted when the test pass
okay so probably what had happened since
before I ran the test and I didn't pass
them it was probably just left over from
then so okay and I saw I think someone
said Sebastian said add that to get
ignore so yeah I should definitely do
that and that'll just that way if it
happens again I don't have to worry
about it
okay so max says the noise of my fan is
annoying so sorry about that
I didn't realize is it can you hear the
fan a lot I had it on low I know I've
done that before and it seemed to be
okay so let me know if it was if the
thane was too much and I'll turn it off
next time
so it seems like max max said buy so I
think max isn't around anymore to let me
know about the the fan noise but I'm
actually okay with max leaving because
the fan noise is annoying it would have
been it would have been much worse if
they said like your voice is annoying or
something because I can't really change
that but I could definitely turn the fan
on
all right so I think I'm good yeah I've
gotten all the questions in the live
chat
hopefully I didn't miss any of near the
top if I did I'm sorry let's see
Sebastian's still having trouble passing
the test all right we're gonna have to
try to get to the bottom of this and I
know it's at least it's hard for me cuz
I I can't I can't recreate the issue so
it's really hard to try to work on them
so alright well we'll try to let's try
to figure that out but if anybody else
is having trouble if you clone the repo
and try to pass the test if you're
having trouble please go to the issue
and it's the only issue open right now
in the repo so check out go to that
issue and comment with any details you
have like screenshots of what what's
happening what system you're running and
things like that that might be helpful
when trying to figure out what what the
problems are so if you are having it you
can do that that would that would just
be super helpful but I really appreciate
that but I think that's it for today I
really appreciate everybody watching and
participating the live chat it's really
cool that we have that slack channel now
so I'll try to remember to put that in
all the descriptions from now on so and
I'll have to join in there as well I
should be able to be back tomorrow I
think at the same time I don't think I
have any meetings going on with some are
Thursday Thursday already yeah it looks
like I'm Thursday should be the same
time 2 p.m. Eastern Time but you know
that my normal time we'll be back will
probably we may be working on this again
on finishing it up we'll see maybe I'll
have time I do have meetings in the
morning so I may not have time to do
much with it but
not really that much else that needs
done with it and until then have a great
day see you tomorrow